[Aplausos]
familiares lloran en la morgue de este
hospital en la ciudad Palestina de Rafa
junto al cuerpo de un líder del
movimiento islamista alcutza
unos 40 aviones y drones de la fuerza
aérea israelí bombardearon durante casi
dos horas la franja de gaza el resultado
tres saltos comandantes de la yihadi
islámica muertos grupo considerado
terrorista por Israel dauth militante de
la yihadi islámica anunció represalias
la respuesta de este crimen la decidirá
la resistencia ellos determinarán su
lugar y tiempo lo importante es que se
ha tomado la decisión de responder habrá
una respuesta Palestina a este crimen
que apuntó a todo el pueblo palestino
los bombardeos se producen menos de una
semana después del anuncio de una tregua
entre las autoridades israelíes y los
combatientes de la yihad islámica el
ataque israelí rompió La tregua y causó
sufrimiento en la población civil los
residentes de este barrio se despertaron
con el sonido de las explosiones otros
murieron
la gente los ancianos y los niños
estaban aterrorizados escuchamos que
había una tregua de 48 o 72 horas pero
los judíos nos traicionaron la gente no
pudo dormir Desde las 4 de la mañana
la semana pasada la muerte de un
palestino bajo custodia israelí tras una
huelga de hambre de más de 80 días
desencadenó varias horas de
enfrentamientos transfronterizos entre
Israel y grupos armados en gaza más de
100 palestinos y al menos 19 israelíes
han muerto desde enero